I need to let other people know there's
a reason why I'm alone you know it's not
because I'm alone
my name is Eli and I'm single I'm like
super single I'm like drinkin Merlot
watching Parks and Rec on a Saturday
night single that's like how single I am
I don't really go out alone by myself I
mean I think it's just really awkward
I'm hoping throughout this week I just
learned to be more comfortable with
myself and to be more comfortable being
alone so we're gonna have to do a dinner
by ourselves go to the movies and $50 do
a date activity there's the only time
I'm unhappy that I'm having this much
money for dinner I've only went out to
eat by myself once I went to a
restaurant I lasted all of like 10
minutes I got the menu I felt like
everyone staring at me I had all this
anxiety and I just got the hell out of
there so I'm hoping I could beat that
anxiety this week well it is the date
portion where I eat dinner by myself
I love Benihana so I wanted to go there
currently alone sitting by myself doing
vlogs is an excuse to look like a creepy
idiot the wait staffs reactions were
similar to me like buying condoms at a
store it's like oh yeah I know whatever
whatever just hide it well just here ago
there was a family there you know
naturally we started talking and got to
know them go ahead but you know it
really forces you to socialize kind of
face those insecurities head-on just
kind of cool
I'm late to the movie I'm like to the
movie I was like in like half hour late
to the movie so I pretty much bailed on
myself this is why I'm single so now I
am having a drink until the next show
needing one seat I could pretty much sit
wherever I want while they're ringing me
up I had all these couples and other
lines like struggling to find like good
seats at the same movie I lasted half
hour by myself I think I'm doing pretty
good
mm-hmm and I'm going into the movie
theater and my seat was seat 20 and
there was a girl sitting at 21 and I
assumed someone was gonna meet her
probably get popcorn for something the
movie starts and she's by herself and I
was like I have to talk to this girl
afterward so I didn't sit next to you
because I assumed someone was coming to
sit next to you I think it's important
to take time for yourself and be with
your own self and be confident in going
out by yourself sure I need that because
I feel like like in like insecure or I
feel like there's a yeah the world the
world sets it up so if you're alone you
look yeah I think I find that stupid
this is really strange I thought you
were you may like hit me with your purse
or run away by me asking for free just
like later
other people change in the world yeah
don't use your cell phones I think the
fact that I went on a date alone and
then I met someone is the success in
itself I'm noticing being alone I'm not
worried about having to cater to
somebody else like I can just kind of
let my guard down and kind of like
almost recharge in a way and I don't
have to constantly worry about the other
person
so it's date number three and I've had a
hard time trying to figure out what I
like to do for a date so I think I'm
gonna do something a little more chill I
decided to do a picnic in my backyard
with just me so I bought some wine and I
got chicken wings mac and cheese
balled out yes yes this is beautiful
thing I'm a simple guy I want to thank
and cheese and I didn't have a blanket
so I had a label mattress I just do it
in my backyard as far as the third day
goes I don't think I've ever done
anything like that with myself might be
the wine talking but I don't know I
really needed this it's really
therapeutic it's almost like kind of
like meditation out of all the dates I
think that was probably the best one eh
because I love chicken wings and - I was
kind of really able just to be in my own
head my wake was great
I feel like when I go to these things
when you're with someone you're just
kind of catering to that person and
giving your energy to them it was almost
like a meditation just the kind of cater
to me when you're alone you're willing
to give your energy within yourself and
kind of be open to the world around you
this gave me confidence to be by myself
if you resent the idea of going out
alone hey I get it but all you really
need is like a glass of wine at a nice
book and you only look smart and you
only look that much sexier
[Music]